We had to,
uh,
some of your recent conversations with
people is we're operating at different
levels,
so Depok fruits,
apple pounds,
me with articles about quantum physics
that show their material stuff is really
just energy.
Atoms are mostly empty space and so forth.
Then you know,
this,
this table is,
you know,
it's actually mostly empty space.
This is all true,
but we don't live at the quantum level.
You live at the pro level where I'm
sitting in a chair and I'm not passing
through it because at that,
at this level,
you know,
it's,
it's not the same as that,
the quantum level.
And,
and I think making that distinction
helps clarify a lot of things.
So like when you talk about the truth
to be found in a biblical stories are,
or literary stories,
like that's the SD or,
or Shakespeare or whatever.
And a material scientist says,
well,
no,
I mean something different by truth.
It's not that one of you is right,
the other's wrong.
It's just that these are different
levels or different ways of talking about
different toolkits.
Yeah.
That,
that's right.
Different tool kits.
That's right.
Yep.
Kind of the classic American pragmatist,
I think of these things as tools.
There's a scientific tool kit and there's
a tool kit for action in the world and
they overlap,
but they're not the same.
So for example,
I call this,
um,
Elvis error,
Alvie singer,
they character in woody Allen's film,
um,
any hall.
And there's that funny scene where
there's a flashback to where he's in
childhood and he's refused to do his
homework and he's depressed and his mother
takes him to the doctor or psychiatrist,
whoever he is.
And okay,
what,
why are you depressed?
Because I found out that
the universe is expanding.
So what?
Because if the universe is expanding and
then eventually it's all going to blow
up and nothing means anything.
Others names Adam,
we live in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn's not expanding
and how to do homework.
That's a nice observation I think too,
because so,
okay,
let's go back to the
conceptualization issues.
So one of the things that we've agreed on,
and I don't want to lose track of that
thread because I think it's useful,
is that we do see an iconic reality
and the icons have practical utility,
but they also bear some one
to one correspondence with
the thing in itself and
it's low resolution is a
nice way of thinking about,
so they're low resolution
icons with functional utility.
Now the question would be,
so then what that makes clear is
that without human consciousness,
all that disappears.
Right?
Okay.
Then the question is partly what is
there outside of that functional iconic
representation.
And so that would be the old
question of the thing in itself.
And you could say,
and I think you could say
with some justification that
the thing in itself is in
potential something that collapses across
time and space so that it's everything
and nothing at the same time,
which is I guess that's an eastern claim.
That's one way of thinking
about it or to Dallas claim.
And I like it because
the problem with the,
or the,
one of the issues that,
and this is associated
with the idea of Brooklyn,
it's not only does lb is
it they all be your LV,
LV,
LV not only does healthy live in Brooklyn,
he lives in Brooklyn now,
right?
And so it's spatially located
and temporarily located.
And so his mother's objection is,
well,
don't pick a reference point that makes
everything right now we irrelevant,
which I,
which is really good
practical psychological advice
because one of the things
that leads people down the
path of nihilism is this
claim that this observation
that you can pick a time frame of
analysis that makes your current action
useless.
Who's going to care in a million years.
The is that,
argues it,
you know,
without God,
without some sort of external source
for morality and meaning nothing.
What we're,
nothing we do matters
because in 15 billion years,
you know,
the heat death of the
universe or whatever,
we don't live 15 billion years from now.
We live now here.
And what we do does matter.
Uh,
you know,
so like the,
this would argue,
you know,
the theodicy problem,
without God,
there's no right or wrong,
whatever Stalin did or
Hitler did is perfectly fine
because of the heat death of
the universe.
No,
it's not fine because the people that
are suffering in the Gulag archipelago or
in the gas chambers,
that outfits,
they're not thinking about
15 billion years from now.
They're,
they're living right here right now.
The torture is really doing wrong,
like these standards.
So again,
the level at which we're
talking about is everything.